the Joe Rogan experience well there's me
at all do you
I don't I can't get injured I'm yes I'm
doing you know I don't know if you know
this but I'm a thespian I'm gonna show
called school where I see guys and you
jump around a lot you lot you're very
physic I'm very fit by the way a dancer
by the way it's do you want to talk
about physical on the show we had Bill
Goldberg on and you know bill I love
that did the best I love him now he
walks around a very trim he's mighty Oh
260 when he was rust he was 280 and and
you don't judge what generalizes he
played professional football for I think
was for seven years so he's the real
deal
and just a real athlete so also a very
nice guy
the best I love him he did a hosted a
show called was it called Garage Mahal
yeah they redid my garage and turns it
into like a like a whole training center
like with a cage a cage and hung heavy
bags and sauce put pictures of like old
UFC fights in the wall it's [ __ ]
amazing he's a guy who brings it 100%
like every time whether it's acting and
so and by the way he comes in and I'm
like your neck looks so thick he goes
first thing I workout first thing he's
well those guys like Chuck Liddell when
you're close to him he breathes
differently like you know and he went
with an L racecar did you sleep he's
like I don't sleep I've been I've been
why and anyway so we had this thing
where I was playing a quarterback that
guy oh it's ridiculous that's what he
looks like right now that's what it
looks like right now and insisted he had
he had a stunt double the stunt double
didn't do anything he did all the stunts
himself to the point where he had he had
to rush at me in a touch football game I
am the quarterback and he had to hit two
dudes for a look at that picture no I
mean smoked a little weed before this
podcast among a lot of people yeah but
that pictures kind of freaking me out
he's got some pig he's so massive he's
but here's the thing about him Matt it's
really interesting that the the
profession of professional wrestling is
unbelievably brutal on your body you
all those guys I don't think get
respected enough for how hard that job
is to do they're doing it hundreds of
nights they can hundred plus nights a
year and they're throwing each other
around and they get smashed but what I
was gonna say is he has come out of it
better than most yes for sure because
he's never stopped working out and he
never stops stretching so we'll be on
set
that guy's stretching he says length is
strength he's he's always moving his
body yeah you know it's like Kurt Angle
told me instead of warrior he told me
that he got injured way more
he said gold medals in the Olympics a
wrestler got what injured way more doing
professional wrestling and for sure and
he taught and and Bill told me the same
thing
but he had to come at me and he said
look I'm gonna come out I'm gonna knock
these two guys down and I'm gonna I'm
coming for your head I'm gonna dive in
so you have to dust on school yes but I
had never seen I've never been that
close to a plug a former pro football
player either stuntmen strong guys but
it's a different thing he would just
come off that line and his speed and he
would hit these two dudes with his he
got dirt like that and the thud that it
sounded like maybe went when two
elephants hit like just you know that
that yeah and they would go they would
they went flying backwards horizontal
and then he comes and dives and would
come for my head and we kept having to
do the take over because I'm a coward
and I would I would you know I look like
a potato bug you know worried I do
anyway
I feel like Goldberg is a guy who could
do the same kind of movies that the rock
does I do tell I feel like he may be a
gigantic movies I think he's a good
actor that's the other thing I think
he's really good on the show look at him
he's a gigantic dude I think he could be
a big movie star I think he could do any
kind of those action movies I know he's
done a bunch yep but I mean I think he
could be a huge megastar he's got all
the personality so really nice I hunt
him smart funny yeah he's with it yeah I
could talk to the guys right there
mmm-hmm and very humble for a [ __ ]
ridiculously huge giant person just but
such a weird athlete
hands his fingers like I was like how do
you dial a cell phone if hangs it too
[ __ ] dick you're hitting two numbers
Jimmy Pedro who was working for Fuji at
the time and they installed oh no he was
working for zebra excuse me at the time
and they if he works for Fuji now and
Jimmy Pedro was a gold medalist Olympics
for judo and Jimmy Pedro set everything
up and he he put the they put these mats
down on like a raised platform so it had
like a little bounce to it like if you
if you fell you got slammed or something
like that and so they tested it out and
so by testing out Jimmy Pedro who
probably weighs 175 maybe let me say you
know with lean thin very strong guys
throwing around Goldberg oh he was yeah
I mean Gober was letting him yes
executing Goldberg will throw himself
but you see Pedro's technique is such
that it's so good that he can do this
Oh like look how easy that's my garage
son so watch how it watch it watch how
he does this I mean this is also this is
Jimmy Pedro way after he's done
competing he teaches now but look at
that boom son look at technique this hip
toss is [ __ ] perfect just perfect
technique look how much bigger
Goldberger is them but he can throw him
around and I was showing Colebrook how
to do it yeah God knows all this [ __ ]
already he ever see him kick and punch
hey man I have I've seen him work out
he's [ __ ] legit as [ __ ] very much
done that's a statement he's [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] legit as [ __ ] I had an
extra [ __ ] to ruin the whole sentence
it's all about harmony yeah but he's
like I said he's with it it's there he's
also like remarkably uninjured for
someone who did what he did for so long
he knows a lot about exercise physiology
oh he's got some bumps I know he's got
some [ __ ] going Robbie he still looks
like him and I mean a lot of these guys
are [ __ ] up man where the back
injuries have forced them to be like
real like very tight rigid they can't
move so good anymore
[Applause]